pasamos mucho tiempo diciendo que los medios no pueden decirnos qué pensar,
y no pueden; son terribles para eso.
Pero ese no es su trabajo.
Los medios no nos dicen qué pensar.
Los medios nos dicen en qué pensar.
Controlan la conversación,
y al controlar la conversación,
no tienen que conseguir que pensemos lo que quieren que pensemos.
Sencillamente nos hacen pensar lo que quieren que pensemos,
y lo más importante, que no pensemos en lo que no quieren que pensemos.
Controlan la conversación.
¿Cómo funciona esto en la práctica?
Tomemos por ejemplo una de esas compañías.
Elegiremos una fácil.
Hablemos de Walt Disney Company por un momento.
Siempre elijo Disney por lo siguiente.
¿Hay alguien en la sala que no haya visto una película de Disney?
Miren alrededor. Exactamente.
Elegí Disney porque tiene lo que llamamos el 100 % de penetración
en nuestra sociedad.
Cada persona ha sido expuesta a Disney,
por eso me resulta fácil de usar.
Desde 1937, Disney hizo la mayor parte de su dinero vendiendo princesas a las niñas.
Una gran parte de su dinero.
A menos que, claro, la princesa que le interesa a su hija sea esta,
como a mi hija.
Vean, en 2012,
Disney compró LucasFilm por USD 4000 millones,
e inmediatamente inundaron las tiendas de Disney con Han Solo
y Obi-Wan Kenobi, con Darth Vader y Luke Skywalker y Yoda,
pero no con la princesa Leia.
¿Por qué? Porque esta princesa desordena la pedagogía pública
de estas princesas.
Disney no puso productos de la princesa Leia en sus tiendas,
y cuando le preguntaron a Disney:
"¿Dónde están los productos de la princesa Leia?"
Disney dijo: "No tenemos intención
de vender productos de la princesa Leia en las tiendas".
Y los fans se enojaron y fueron a Twitter
con el hashtag #WeWantLeia.
Y Disney dijo: "Esperen, eso no es lo que quisimos decir.
Quisimos decir que
que aún no tenemos princesa Leia, pero la vamos a tener".
Eso fue en 2012, y estamos en 2015,
y si van a la tienda de Disney, como yo fui hace poco,
y buscan a la princesa Leia,
¿saben cuántas princesa Leia hay en la tienda de Disney?
Cero, porque Disney no tiene intención de poner a la princesa Leia en la tienda.
Y no debería sorprendernos porque observamos que fue su política
cuando compraron Marvel en 2009
por USD 4500 millones.
Porque cuando uno gana mucho dinero vendiendo princesas para niñas,
también quiere ganar dinero con los niños.
¿Y qué mejor para los niños que venderle superhéroes?
Así que Disney ahora tenía acceso al Capitán América y Thor,
al increíble Hulk,
y tenía acceso incluso
a un grupo de superhéroes de los que nadie jamás había oído hablar.
Marvel era muy buena en la venta de superhéroes.
El año pasado, lanzaron la película "Guardianes de la galaxia".
Es una película que no debió funcionar.
Nadie conocía a esos superhéroes, salvo los nerds como yo.
Uno de los personajes es un árbol que habla.
Otro, un mapache antropomórfico.
No debió funcionar.
E hicieron una superestrella de "Guardianes de la galaxia".
Este personaje del medio, su nombre es Gamora,
interpretado por Zoe Saldana,
es fuerte e inteligente, veloz, y pelea como una ninja,
interpretado por una hermosa mujer negra,
y mi hija se enamoró de ella.
Como cualquier buen padre nerd, fui a comprarle productos de Gamora,
y cuando llegué a la tienda, aprendí algo muy interesante.
Si quería comprarle una mochila de Gamora,
bueno, no había de Gamora.
Quizá deberían haberlo comercializado como "algo" de Guardianes de la galaxia.
(Risas)
Si quería comprarle una fiambrera, no había de Gamora,
y si quería comprarle una camiseta,
no había de Gamora.
Y, de hecho,
si iba a la tienda, como lo hice,
y observaba el expositor,
se veía una imagen pequeña de Gamora aquí,
pero en los productos en esa estantería,
no aparece Gamora en ninguno.
Podría haber ido a Twitter con el hashtag #WheresGamora,
como hicieron millones de fans en todo el mundo,
pero la verdad es que ni siquiera me sorprendió
porque estuve allí cuando Disney lanzó "The Avengers".
Y este año llegó la nueva película de los vengadores, la "Era de Ultron",
y estábamos muy emocionados,
porque no había una sino dos superheroínas,
Bruja Escarlata y Viuda Negra.
Estábamos muy emocionados.
Pero esto fue lo que pasó.
Aunque Scarlett Johansson,
una de las actrices más populares de EE.UU., interpreta a la Viuda Negra,
y la Viuda Negra es la estrella
no de una ni dos, sino de cinco películas de Marvel,
no hay ni un producto de la Viuda Negra disponible.
Ni uno.
Y si van a la tienda de Disney a buscar un traje de Viuda Negra,
encontrarán de Capitán América y de Increíble Hulk.
Encontrarán Iron Man y Thor.
Es posible incluso encontrar Máquina de Guerra,
que ni siquiera aparece realmente en la película tanto tiempo.
Pero no encontrarán a la Viuda Negra.
Y podría haber ido a Twitter con el hashtag, como muchas personas,
#WheresNatasha.
Pero me cansé de hacer eso.
Estoy cansado de tener que hacerlo.
En todo el país ahora mismo,
hay niños que juegan con el kit Cycle Blast Quinjet,
en el que el Capitán América monta una moto en un avión en movimiento
y realmente es asombroso.
¿Saben cuán asombroso es?
Tan asombroso que cuando ocurrió en la película,
lo hizo la Viuda Negra.
No solo la eliminaron,
sino que la reemplazaron por una figura masculina.
¿Qué nos enseña esto?
Es decir, en los próximos cinco años,
Disney y Warner Bros. y un grupo de estudios de cine
van a lanzar más de 30 largometrajes
con personajes de cómic,
y de esos 30 largometrajes,
exactamente dos de ellos tendrán protagonistas femeninos.
Dos.
Habrá mujeres en el resto de estas películas,
pero serán compinches, intereses amorosos,
miembros de los equipos.
No serán las protagonistas.
Y si lo que aprendemos o sabemos
sobre otras personas y sobre el mundo es a través de los medios,
entonces estas empresas están enseñando a mi hija que, incluso si ella es fuerte,
inteligente, veloz, y lucha como una ninja,
cuatro cosas que son así en su caso,
eso no importa.
O bien será ignorada como Gamora,
o eliminada y reemplazada por un niño
como en el caso de Viuda Negra.
Y no es justo.
No es justo para ella y no es justo para sus hijos e hijas tampoco.
Pero el tema es este:
Estoy criando a una niña que es un poco marimacho,
y por cierto es terrible llamar así a una chica.
Eso básicamente refleja que esos rasgos que la definen,
en realidad no son propios,
sino un préstamo de los niños por un breve tiempo.
Pero ¿saben el dolor que tendrá que enfrentar en su vida
por ser un poco marimacho?
Cero. Nada.
La gente pensará que es linda.
Será tildada de decidida, porque en nuestra sociedad
llamar a las chicas con los así llamados rasgos masculinos
es como una mejora, como tener un plus.
No estoy criando un niño pequeño, como Mike.
Mike es un niño pequeño de Florida, EE.UU. y tiene 11 años,
y lo que más le gusta en el mundo
es un programa llamado "Mi pequeño pony: La amistad es mágica",
como millones de otros niños en EE.UU.
El programa se comercializa para niñas de 5 a 9 años,
pero hay millones de niños,
y hombres adultos,
que disfrutan de "Mi pequeño pony: La amistad es mágica".
Tienen un club.
Se hacen llamar Bronies,
hermanos en el pony, personas a las que les gustan los ponis.
A mí me gustaban.
Y ¿qué aprendimos Mike y yo
y millones de otros niños y hombres acerca de este mundo femenino,
amariconado de "Mi pequeño pony?"
Aprendimos a estudiar arduamente, a trabajar mucho, a festejar a lo grande,
a verse bien y sentirse bien
y hacer el bien,
y que el cielo nos libre de enseñar estas ideas de cobardes a los niños.
Por eso los niños del barrio golpearon a Mike
y se burlaron de él,
y con 11 años, Mike vuelve a casa,
encuentra un cinturón, se lo coloca alrededor del cuello,
y se cuelga desde lo alto de su cama.
Porque hemos desarrollado una sociedad
en la que es preferible morir como niño a pensar que le gustan cosas de niñas.
Y no es culpla de Mike. Es nuestra culpa.
A él le hemos fallado.
Hemos fallado a nuestros hijos.
Y tenemos que darles algo mejor.
Tenemos que dejar de hacer que las únicas superheroínas
vistan camisas de color rosa a medida de las niñas.
Tenemos que parar.
Cuando juntaba todo esto, me decían:
"Bueno, eso nunca va a suceder". Y les dije: "¿En serio?"
Porque solo este año, Target anunció
que dejarán de clasificar por género sus pasillos de juguetes.
Los van a mezclar.
Pero antes de fundirnos en un abrazo con Target por esto,
esta misma semana lanzaron una camisa
con una de las escenas más icónicas de "Star Wars: Una nueva esperanza",
en la que la princesa Leia está frente al Señor Oscuro de los Sith...
lanzaron una camiseta
en la que Leia es misteriosamente reemplazada por Luke.
Así que tampoco festejemos tanto.
Esta misma semana también,
Disney anunció que ya no clasificará por género sus disfraces de Halloween;
a lo que digo: "Gracias, Disney,
salvo que los únicos trajes que hacen son de superhéroes,
entonces, ¿importa quién los use?"
Esta misma semana, Mattel, que fabrica la Barbie,
anunció que van a lanzar una línea de chicas superheroínas del DC.
Y lo curioso es que
se reunieron con niñas
y les preguntaron qué querían ver en las muñecas,
y pueden ver, tienen brazaletes
y codos que se doblan, por lo que pueden hacer cosas de superhéroes.
Por favor, cómprenlas.
Y no solo para sus hijas,
cómprenlas también para sus hijos.
Porque es importante que ellos jueguen 'con' y 'como' superheroínas,
así como mi hija juega 'con' y 'como' superhéroes.
De hecho, me encantaría
un mundo en el que cada persona que va a la tienda
vaya con un pequeño diagrama de flujo en la cabeza
de si debería o no comprar un juguete para un niño o una niña,
y es un diagrama muy simple porque contiene solo una pregunta.
Es decir: "Este juguete, ¿se maneja con los genitales?"
(Risas)
Si la respuesta es sí,
no es un juguete para niños.
(Risas)
Y si la respuesta es no,
es un juguete para niños y niñas.
Es muy simple.
Porque hoy se trata del futuro del futuro, y en mi futuro,
los niños y las niñas se respetan por igual,
son igualmente valiosos y, más importante, igualmente representados.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)